frauen in der politik meinen armen
darüber schlichtweg gegen die göttliche
ordnung
nein ich bin nämlich fürs
frauenstimmrecht
zum glück ist ihre meinung nicht
ausschlaggebend der film hat die
göttliche ordnung und es geht um die
einführung des frauenstimmrechts in der
schweiz sehr sehr spät fanden sich 1971
1971 war die welt in bewegung
aber hier bei uns war es zu heiß auf die
zeit stehen
die schweiz war damals innerhalb europas
tatsächlich ein bisschen hinterher also
deutschland hatte von 1918 eingeführt
die skandinavischen länder schon vor dem
ersten weltkrieg deutlich und es ist
tatsächlich so kommt auch im film vor
dass damals in der schweiz 1,9 millionen
frauen gelebt haben und 16 millionen
männer
das heißt die minderheit hat über die
mehrheit vollkommen mitbestimmt wer ist
dagegen die hauptfigur ist nur arg
gespielt von marie leuenberger
nora hat ein mann und zwei kinder und
nun möchte gerne wieder arbeiten
aber ihr mann möchte das nicht weißt du
was ich wie bei der arbeit anhören
müssen frau muss arbeiten weil er zu
wenig geld nach hause bringt
nora ich will das nicht aber die könnten
doch wenigstens mal probieren nein nora
und ohne meine zustimmung kannst du das
auch gar nicht so ist das gesetz
und da fällt überhaupt erst mal auf dass
die männer über die frauen komplett mit
bestimmen dass die männer alleine die
gesetze machen die auch mal die frauen
entscheiden und da fängt sie plötzlich
an den kampf für das frauenstimmrecht
eine gute sache halten und sich zu
engagieren
[Musik]
er findet heute besonders relevant weil
es heute so selbstverständlich wird dass
frauen wählen gehen dürfen und auch
natürlich zur wahl stehen dürfen
und man sieht wie kurzes erst her ist
dass es überhaupt nicht
selbstverständlich waren
man sieht also wie gesellschaftliche
veränderungen die teilweise sich auch
überfällig waren einem wenige jahrzehnte
später vorkommen als hätte es natürlich
immer schon so sein müssen weil es
einfach fair ist ich würde gern mit
meiner frau reden aber die nicht mit dir
die marien leider die die nora spielt
macht es wirklich sehr gut und hat auch
zurecht preise dazu bekommen
max simonischek spielt ihren mann und
beide machen etwas wirklich gut nämlich
dass sie wenig machen
nora mit den streit erreicht jedoch
nicht ganz im gegenteil
da gibt es keine großen pathetischen
momente und es gibt auch nicht bei
beiden den einen umschwung die epiphanie
sondern man sieht wirklich wie sich
allmählich diese menschen und ihre
meinungen aus formen
du hast noch nie
neben eigentlich sollte sich jeder
diesen film ansehen das ist total egal
ob man sich jetzt besonders für
feminismus oder politik interessiert es
ist nämlich einfach auch ein sehr
lustiger film
man kann sich die schweiz sowieso immer
mal 90 minuten im kino anschauen und die
schauspieler sind gut
es gibt überhaupt keinen grund sich
diesen nicht anzuschauen weg ist die
reservierung für das lokale
aktionskomitee frauenstimmrecht zwei
fakten der gemeinde zu schweigen
so steht es in der bibel du sollst nicht
ehebrechen steht auch in der bibel